officially myanmar says there are only a
few dozen new infections a day
observers say that can't be true there's
hardly any testing going on
there are reports of a lack of staff in
testing centers hospitals have the same
problem
with doctors and nurses joining strikes
against the military which seized power
four months ago
they've been attacks on healthcare
workers
as schools reopen some teachers and
students are also making a stand
defying the junta's calls for full
classrooms
which would only help the virus spread
[Music]
hundreds of thousands of people across
myanmar have been calling for an end to
the military takeover
the country is in turmoil and the
healthcare system
is one of the worst affected sectors
doctors and nurses were the first to go
on strike
thousands refusing to work under a
military regime
but that also poses a problem for covert
patients
mayan bosoyan is head of mission for
doctors without borders
in myanmar and joins us from yangon tell
us about the difficulties of your work
first of all i mean you're trying to
save lives at the same time as
um putting your own lives at risk
um yeah that's that's true and that's uh
being part of
msf i guess at the moment though um
the threats on our lives is not
very high the situation for the people
in myanmar is very severe
but for the actual international staff
of msf it's it's not
it is for our national staff
challenging period not only asking we
them to to do more than we usually do we
are upscaling our activities
due to the increased needs at the same
time they're facing psychological
stress from from what is going on in
their own country so yes for our
our staff our national staff here in the
office we have around
1100 people it's a very testing
testing time um but we are doing our
atmos best to um
to bring the services we want to bring
uh in
in these times when we witnessing a a
breakdown of a public health system here
in myanmar
and i guess the psychological impact
also
has a a political angle to it
the who is talking about 179 attacks on
medical staff and facilities
since the military took over also 13
deaths dozens
of arrests i mean how do you go about
reaching the people when health
professionals are being attacked
yes um specifically the the health
facility the health workers that are
uh on cdn so the civil disobedience
movements are targeted
uh these are the health workers working
for the public sector
you still have the health workers
working for private sector or for
charity
sector like like for msf so our doctors
are
continuing their work they're not
striking
and therefore they're less of a target
directly
but you can see the fear among our staff
as well
and that's basically from coming to the
office
having to pass a lot of police checks
potentially being searched there is
definitely a fear
um we are not directly the target
because we're not working
uh in the public health sector and we
are not um
joining the the civil disobedient
movement
but you you you the the natural stuff is
uh is definitely uh very aware and very
um tense i would say ayan can you
tell us just how dire the situation is
with covert or how bad the numbers are i
believe the data isn't reliable
the data is totally not reliable so
after the military takeover
the basically the country stopped
testing there
the whole um testing facilities the
the vaccination program came to stand
still
there are a few hundred tests a day but
did nothing but compared to
uh the the military takeover which means
we don't have reliable data on the
cockpit
um which also means that we are
besides the whole prevention let's say
testing tracing
vaccination um there's also a lot of
things happening in the country that are
conducive for probits let's say the
mass demonstrations the whole banking
system is collapsing so there are
long queues for atms like really long
um and and and in the region uh in india
and bangladesh there are
varieties of coffee that are rampant so
we are really worried
of a third wave outbreak in myanmar with
the
mr health system uh at this at the
current
status let's get another view from
georgina phillips an emergency physician
in australia who's trained doctors and
nurses in myanmar
and has published a call for solidarity
in the lancet
some of the authors of that letter have
fled the country are in hiding or have
been detained
i asked georgina though about the
consequences of the coup for the people
of myanmar
so the government health system has
essentially
collapsed as a result of the civil
disobedience movement
and the targeting of healthcare workers
so
therefore everyday healthcare systems
are not available for the people
and people suffering from covert for
example are
neither getting tested nor able to
access emergency care
the consequence for healthcare workers
is intimidation and arrest
or or fleeing the country
and so it's a health system in
collapse and
during the covert pandemic now we can
anticipate that there's
a surge happening in myanmar that
bordering countries are going through a
surge
mortality and morbidity morbidity
statistics are not available we don't
know
testing is not available we don't know
how many people are positive
and people are frightened to go to
health care services
they might themselves might be targeted
uh the healthcare services are extremely
limited
there's charity clinics there's private
clinics but they're they're limited in
what they can provide for people
and therefore we anticipate that people
are suffering not only
worsening of their normal health
condition but quite likely
uh suffering from the escalation and
surge of the covert pandemic
this wasn't always the way it was
georgina you mentioned before the coup
that health facilities were in good
shape
that's true so prior to the coup the
covert response in myanmar was quite
robust
my colleagues in the emergency care
systems in emergency medicine were
leading the clinical response
the government hospitals had quite
strong
testing screening triage and critical
care
responses there was a system for
treatment escalation of treatment
transfer of covert positive patients
there was a robust public health
response people
of course for a public health response
you need people to be
trusting in their in their ministry of
health and their government systems
and that was happening uh there was
contact tracing
and the vaccination vaccination program
was rolling out
the military coup of the 1st of february
has
called a halt to all of those activities
and most of those things are no longer
progressing
the doctor i spoke to before said
myanmar wouldn't be able to handle a
third wave what
what is coming their way do you think
i think it's quite likely likely that
there is a third wave
happening in myanmar at the moment the
there's no
available reliable data i think you can
anticipate that that is
that is happening given uh the
neighboring countries the situation of
the neighbouring countries
and i do think that myanmar will not be
able to handle this surge
the government hospitals are barely
functioning
government health workers are very
limited
the workforce is severely restricted and
the charity clinics and the private
hospitals are not able to provide a
service and the people
are most reluctant to attend the
military hospitals
so in terms of accessing
acute care for covert for people with
acute
infection and serious symptoms that will
be severely
diminished in terms of contact tracing
and the public health response
that's that's minimal and the
vaccination program i think is also
severely restricted time for
derrick williams and your questions on
the coronavirus
if some people can still get the virus
even after being vaccinated
is herd immunity even possible
questions like this are why many
scientists don't
like the term herd immunity because they
feel the word
immunity implies a point where the
pandemic
suddenly stops a lot of them prefer the
term
herd protection because vaccine drives
don't
make everyone in a population magically
immune
when enough people have had the shot
they just they just help protect people
who are still
vulnerable and protection implies
ongoing vigilance which is what pretty
much all the experts say we're going to
need
going forward and there are a few
reasons
why herd protection will be very
difficult to achieve
not least that as you say a few people
still contract the disease even after
full vaccination
and can presumably pass it on to others
this phenomenon is called vaccine
failure and the person that happens to
is known as a breakthrough case but data
from the end of april
from the u.s has confirmed something
that had been reported from israel which
is that
breakthrough cases at least so far
look exceedingly rare um that could of
course
change as as more time passes but right
now
the data look great um it's a sign
that herd protection might not be
unachievable at least in some local or
regional or
or even maybe national contexts but even
if transmission
is brought largely under control in some
places a few experts believe
sars kobe 2 is just going to go away
because to wipe out the virus we'd have
to hit vaccination goals globally which
will take years and in the meantime
immunity could begin to wane in those
who were
already vaccinated or the virus could
still mutate in ways
that would make herd protection even
harder to achieve
you